[Musica]
[Applauso]
3000 metri sul livello del mare
Siamo nel mese di febbraio ha smesso di
nevicare da poche ore
intorno a me cime e valli
completamente rivestite da un manto di
neve bianca
davanti a me un ghiacciaio su cui sto
per iniziare una discesa con un gruppo
di amici nel mio cuore un senso di
infinito
3000 metri sul livello del mare
stesso posto è passato qualche tempo e
siamo a settembre
intorno a me qualche cima bianca e valli
completamente brulle davanti a me un
ghiacciaio o meglio una lingua di
ghiaccio
sofferente
schiacciata delle rocce circostanti
rocce il caldo estivo rende a dir poco
incandescente
cerco su internet qualche foto di questo
stesso ghiacciaio e scopro che 100 anni
prima era completamente diverso ma era
molto diverso anche 50 anni prima ed era
diverso anche solo 30 anni prima era
gigante Maestoso era il vero
protagonista della scena
Ebbene sì i ghiacciai Alpini si stanno
sciogliendo lo sentiamo dire spesso ma
qual è la portata di questo fenomeno
Eddai sulle Alpi hanno perso metà del
proprio volume dall'inizio del secolo
scorso ad oggi ma c'è un dato ancora più
allarmante
meno
89% entro il 2100 i ghiacciai Alpini
rischiano di perdere fino al 89% del
proprio volume entro la fine di questo
secolo
i ghiacciai alpini sono vittime del
cambiamento climatico
il motivo per cui si stanno sciogliendo
così rapidamente è uno e uno solo e il
surriscaldamento globale Ecco che noi
dobbiamo agire fin da subito come
andando a ridurre le emissioni di CO2 è
una cosa che siamo chiamati a fare tutti
noi tutti i giorni
c'è un Ma per il fenomeno scientifico
del climategate se anche oggi
raggiungessi mo La neutralità tra il
livello di CO2 immessa nell'atmosfera e
quella che L'atmosfera è in grado di
osservare di assorbire vedremo l'effetto
positivo in termini di riduzione delle
temperature globali
solo tra qualche decennio
Peccato che i ghiacciai alpini non hanno
qualche decennio specie quelli siti alle
altitudini più basse
il percorso per ridurre le emissioni di
CO2 è lungo e complicato Però
diciamocelo è una strada che non
possiamo evitare
richiede che si mette in moto una
macchina globale costituita dalle
organizzazioni internazionali dagli
Stati dalle aziende e da ciascuno di noi
però
nell'immediato se qualcosa che possiamo
fare per proteggere alcuni dei ghiacciai
ti amiamo
Ecco ce lo siamo chiesti io Sara
Giovanni e Pietro siamo un gruppo di 4
amici tutti classe 1998 Eccoci Nella
foto ci siamo conosciuti tra i banchi
dell'università Bocconi
allora abbiamo guardato con ammirazione
alle esempio di una serie di località
che sull'arco Alpino vanno a coprire il
proprio ghiacciaio durante la stagione
estiva con le grandi tele bianche
Ecco che con altrettanto ammirazione
abbiamo letto una serie di studi studi
che misuravano l'efficacia di questo
meccanismo di protezione
capiamo insieme di che cosa si tratta
sostanzialmente si va a coprire il
ghiacciaio nella stagione estiva con dei
grandi teli Bianchi
Teli che sono a posti nel mese di maggio
e rimossi a settembre
immaginatevi dei grandi tappeti bianchi
che sono sono rotolati da cima a Valle
del ghiacciaio sono poi affiancati gli
uni gli altri e cuciti tra di loro ora
dove applicati Questi te li riescono a
salvare fino alla totalità del ghiaccio
sottostante quindi diciamo che la loro
efficacia è massima però l'attività di
protezione del ghiacciaio con questi
teli e complessa e dispendiosa Ecco che
serve un modello per renderla
sostenibile prendere la scala B
gli studenti di business abbiamo fatto i
compiti a casa e abbiamo guardato con
interesse a una serie di realtà che da
anni rendono grandi sfide ambientali
alla portata di tutti
pensiamo a quelle realtà che rimuovono
la plastica dagli oceani andando così a
tutelare le specie che li abitano
pensiamo poi a tutte quelle aziende che
piantano alberi finanziati dalla propria
Community
per andare a compensare le emissioni di
CO2 dell'uomo
e pensiamo ancora a quelle realtà che
combattono il problema dello spreco di
cibo come distribuendo il cibo non
venduto dai proprio tempo
perché non fare lo stesso per proteggere
i ghiacciai alpini
Questo è quello che ci siamo chiesti è
da tutte queste riflessioni ha preso
vita la nostra Startup
si tratta di una realtà che coinvolge
persone e aziende nella salvaguardia dei
ghiacciai alpini
sostanzialmente le persone le aziende
interessate attraverso la nostra
piattaforma
adottano una porzione di ghiacciaio la
porzione adottata andrà coperta nella
stagione estiva successiva Per far sì
che il ghiaccio non si scioglie
Permettetemi di dire che è un'attività
di questo tipo è veramente complessa
sfidante mandare a custodire un
ghiacciaio Alpino è un'attività che
richiede il coinvolgimento di tutta una
serie di attori
Ecco che ci piace pensare alla nostra
realtà come un sistema un sistema ti
abbraccia tutte le figure necessarie per
la buona riuscita
partiamo delle comunità locali
ora Mettiamoci nei panni di chi vive nei
pressi di un ghiacciaio di chi quindi di
anno in anno ne osserva l'inesorabile
arretramento Ecco le comunità locali
sono proprio i beneficiari ultimi della
nostra iniziativa dato che vedono
preservato custodito il ghiacciaio della
propria località
comunità scientifica Quindi tutti quegli
scienziati che studiano i ghiacciai su
cui operiamo e che vanno a misurare
l'efficacia dell'attività di protezione
che proponiamo
aziende sponsor
pensiamo a tutte quelle aziende che già
integrano la sostenibilità nel proprio
operato e Clean più vogliano Prendere
parte a una climate Action nuova
dall'impatto tangibile e misurabile
infine ci siamo tutti noi
noi che abbiamo ancora il pianeta noi
che abbiamo a cuore la montagna noi che
desideriamo proteggere i ghiacciai
Alpini e custodirne alcuni Per chi verrà
dopo di no ecco comunità locali comunità
scientifiche aziende sponsor e tutti noi
questo è il sistema che abbiamo pensato
per rispondere una grande sfida dei
nostri giorni
intervista alla nostra realtà abbiamo
scelto il modello della società bene Ora
non so quanti di voi lo conoscano si
tratta di un modello disegnato in
America appena nel 2010 è arrivato in
Europa giusto nel 2016 con l'Italia che
è stato il primo paese a inserirlo nel
proprio corpo normativo
ora una società Benefit altro non è che
una società nata per avere un impatto
positivo sulle persone e sulla biosfera
un impatto che nel nostro specifico caso
è in linea con quelli che sono gli
obiettivi di sviluppo sostenibile
dell'agenda 20-30 delle Nazioni Unite
si tratta di obiettivi comuni che
riguardano tutti i paesi tutti gli
individui nel nostro specifico caso
proviamo a dare risposta all'obiettivo
di combattere il cambiamento climatico è
l'obiettivo di proteggere una fonte
d'acqua pulita
abbiamo scelto il modello della società
Benefit perché crediamo fermamente che
business e sostenibilità vadano insieme
crediamo più un buon modello di business
sia il carburante di una buona causa e
crediamo ancora che sia responsabilità
della nostra generazione dimostrarlo
come dando vita tutta una serie di
realtà che nel loro piccolo
rispondano alle grandi sfide dei nostri
giorni
realtà come la nostra
nate per una buona causa guidate da un
obiettivo di valore
tutto questo non è altro che il
desiderio di 4 amici di proteggere i
ghiacciai Alpini e di custodirne alcuni
Per chi verrà dopo di noi e appena preso
vita
[Applauso]